happy New Year everyone we're excited to
kick off 2024 with you now get ready
because we have a huge show ahead we are
taking a look back at our musty moments
from our show last year we're answering
your fan mail questions and we're also
going to rewind to one of our favorite
things which is one more thing plus it's
our annual tradition we're revealing our
New Year's resolutions and predictions
but
first it's the best five stories of 23
first up is the viral moment of the year
I don't give to but I am telling you
right
now back there is not real Tiffany Gomez
known as the crazy plane lady setting
lady setting the internet ablazed after
confronting a not real man on the flight
Jesse you had her on Prime Time what
happened I did she never told us what
she saw she said there was a guy and he
didn't put his seat back and he didn't
try to hit on her so I have no idea what
happened the judge said I booted the
interview she said I should have crushed
this poor lady and I've just I've lost
sleep over it no you haven't and I
haven't what would you have asked judge
well first of all if if first of all she
was charged with criminal trespass
everyone on that plane had to get off
the plane then they had to go through
security again and then she tried to
board the train again the plane again
and you know she acts like oh you know I
was just so upset well if she wants us
to believe that she had an argument with
someone what was your argument about you
don't if you have an argument you say he
touched me he sold from me he pushed his
seat on me you don't say he's not real I
would say to her were you on something
you know did you drink something do you
act like this normally have you seen a
doctor have you seen a
psychiatrist Jessica do you think she
just needed a minute
I I don't know I it really transformed
my way of thinking once Jesse had her
and she seemed pretty normal and mellow
and then know Greg obviously loves to
insert uh substances into the
conversation of what might have happened
and then I was like maybe she was on
something maybe she just like had a
complete adverse reaction to whatever
cocktail um had been consumed um but it
was a fun story at least while it last
tort I'm trying to make my flight you
travel a lot if this happened on your
flight what would you listen I I love
the Twilight Zone you know there was a
man on the plane no one believed William
Shatner there was something on the plane
there was something on the plane and
ended up guess what there was something
on the plane so she knows better than to
talk cuz you know what happens when you
talk about invisible people ghosts or
aliens you disappear so obviously it was
real to her and so therefore she should
not fly ever especially on a flight that
I'm on right but you know and judge she
was dressed for success and just like
you are apparently the party was pretty
good last
night young lady you care to explain
what my lips are sealed for the
producers sake okay all right well let's
go to this one next up remember this
heart stopping moment during a
podcast so quiet in here how did
I
yes an SUV crashing right into a coffee
shop window in Houston as two podcasters
were in the middle of a live broadcast
don't worry they were all okay and they
were joking about it a little bit later
what do you think of that the driver
lost control no I'm I'm calling uh
what's the appropriate word BS on this
one uh this was staged th% staged first
of all what a crazy turn to make one a
straight line it wasn't like he had to
make the turn and when since when do you
do an interview with the blinds off up
okay and a car is coming you run you
move they didn't even Flinch cuz they
knew it was coming nor did they have any
concern for the
driver wow I never thought somebody hits
the wall you don't jump up and be like
okay and once you find out you're okay
then would then that's when the epit
would come out what are you effing crazy
you could have killed me but no even the
camera doesn't move it as if the
mathematical possibilities of this
happen
I I don't have Harold or Charles Payne
here with me but is astronomical this
you have a better chance of winning two
lotteries than this being at the right
place at the right time for a car
speeding but not quite speeding enough
that's quite a Stunt Driver though if so
right is it my 9-year-old could pull
that off you know what's missing from
this story was the guy arrested was he
tested for alcohol here we go again with
drugs I mean the driver conspiracy
conspiracy conspiracy and but but the
reason they didn't know it was coming is
cu they don't have eyes in the back of
their heads but I agree with you because
this guy is driving straight and then
all of a sudden drives right into this
and why by the way the shades are down
did you see them move shades are down no
the shades are up enough to catch the
spot they're down on the other side and
here's one other thing Jud objection
other over you're here here's the other
thing judge judge you have a natural
response you don't have to see something
to move you would feel it not to mention
you would hear
of the car here's why I don't think
you're right Jesse it was a 38-year-old
woman driving the car
even so would you trust a woman to pull
the stunt off Cyrus you probably
absolutely badgering the witness what
makes you think women will drive like
stunt men give me a break how many stunt
women drivers are there
thousands yeah yeah you are how do you
think she got here in the party also
Jessica she also ran into collided with
the white Ford Escape lost control
that's what she and she did get she got
a citation for running a red light
that's it that was it oh the system
works doesn't it this is sucking the fun
out of it why can't it just be like a
real thing that happened oh no because I
we're not sucking fun I think the fun
has been sucked no one sucked fun nope
this fun does not suck at all all right
next up I love this one fashion is so
out of control that when a prankster
crash the runway at a New York Fashion
Show wearing a trash bag no one even
noticed judge you could have been in the
audience there would you have noticed I
wouldn't have noticed to be honest with
you I like the way you would look that
you're laughing I like the way he just
kind of walks slowly he's got sticking
that butt out going back and forth and
then all of a sudden when he looks back
you know that he's in trouble
it's I think it's great and it looks
like what you would expect to see at a
fashion forward fashion show you dress
for the job you want Jessie sure all the
suckers in the front world were like oh
yeah yeah I that I could see
that, for that shower curtain right y he
literally got 150 orders for that outfit
that's right I I think again I'm so
happy it's 2024 because 2023 I'm just
over it this says more about the fashion
industry than it does him the fact that
you can put a shower cap on and a
see-through trash bag and stroll down
and everybody's fine with it and at some
point somebody yelled out he's so brave
so you know when the security guard took
him off why he wasn't a threat to
anything if he would have turned around
he would have sold them all to every
distributor been at Neiman Marcus it
would have been everywhere Nordstrom's
Rack we would all seen people walking
around remember the yay did that yeah so
why not oh yeah I remember yay all right
next up important life advice always do
a quick Google search new Yark New
Jersey becoming a sister city with a
fake country the city's mayor invited
what he thought was the Hindu nation of
kyasa for an official
ceremony
relationship helps us to understand cult
soci development lives
everybody plac but guys it was totally
fake New York Democrats forced to admit
they were scammed calling it a
regretable incident and the guy behind
it is a no notorious scam artist you got
to do a little Google search before
listen everyone gets catfish when you
lead with your heart they were
desperately looking for their soulmate
City and said all the right things it
was confusing though whenever they
wanted to have a meeting on Facebook or
FaceTime or VD their country's video
camera never worked but you know it was
one of those things where but they just
believed it to be true so let's not be
too hard on them because you know love
will blind are you turning over a new
Lea in no actually if this was anyone I
knew I'd still be laughing at them but
again I'm trying to be nice trying to
nice with their heart or their virtue
because they wanted a little Indian
love sing Look What I look what we've
done look at our sister those things
even exist oh yeah sister C sure oh yes
little Google search you'll find out who
your sister city is yes AB that's a big
deal all right I'm on it a big deal I
could do a Google search put my address
in and end up as someone else's house so
do all my packages so Google isn't that
Savage it's been one of those holiday
seasons yes yes their stuff comes to me
my stuff goes to them my stuff is are
you guys friends yeah thank God do you
know what happened to me I sent a gift
to somebody but I accidentally put East
rather than West okay so in New York you
can imagine what happened so this person
finally calls me they're like I don't
know what to do with this thing and then
as we're talking he's like wait is this
sta Pino and then they were a huge fan
of the five and I said you know what
keep it and I ordered another one I got
to remember that sweet go send me a gift
oh I put
West anyway and finally this year we
started calling him the Secretary of
shredding Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin picking up a guitar and singing
the blues while at a diplomatic event
well aoch
cooch everybody
knows so I realized that I was not here
for that I think I was in Spain yeah I
didn't see that do you think he's got a
future after Secretary of
State I think he likes his line of work
um but and he has another term coming up
you all heard me say that um but I loved
it I thought it was really fun and he's
very talented judge you'd be the judge
of that you liked it when we first saw I
like the fact that he can turn over a
leaf and do something different good for
him he's having fun can you play guitar
uh the flute flute
ow phenomenally yes B and Pop I hate to
agree with Jessica and you know how much
I hate to agree with you but I I think
he was pretty Shing women love that I
didn't know that me this is the one time
I'll say this he can go ahead and quit
his day job really he should go after
this fulltime SCH follow your dreams yes
quit immediately resign go on the road
full time all right you got something
there kid yeah hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else